is friday morning and today is passover
jewish holiday known as seder and uh
you've got a guest with us yes we do
joining us today is rabbi levi harlig
with the shabbat of southern nevada
thank you so much for being with us
today good to see you again for having
me happy passover is it too early to say
that it's a little bit too early but
starts tonight eight nights eight days
happy passover happy pesach in hebrew
okay
all right let's talk about the the
holiday why is it so important to the
jewish community so this is a piece that
started 3300 over 300 years ago jewish
people
as many times in our history were
welcomed to the land of egypt but then
pharaoh the king and the nation turned
against the jewish people and enslaved
us
back breaking labor
moses was born moses is the savior god
said go to pharaoh and have him redeem
the jews moses goes to pharaoh pharaoh
refuses and he brings the ten plagues
upon the egyptians the blood frogs it's
disgusting
and the story of pacifier at length the
jews finally after the tenth plague the
jews leave egypt and as they're leaving
egypt they wanted baked bread but they
had no time they were rushing out so the
bread didn't have time to rise that's
the passover matzah that's why we have
the matzah and the jews left egypt
splitting of the sea and they went
eventually to the land of israel so it's
a really really special holiday about
the the time of our redemption time of
our freedom i was going to say signifies
freedom and you were talking about this
bread actually comes
from a country right now who is fighting
for their freedom yes actually this mata
was baked in ukraine you want to support
ukraine ukraine through that they
supplied most of this ishmatsa handmade
from ukraine and we distributed it to
thousands of families here in las vegas
they can celebrate the holiday celebrate
passover while having our brothers and
sisters in ukraine in mind as well
is there a universal prayer of peace
right now for uh ukraine and what
they're going through with russia so we
always add in our prayers and saying the
saying of psalms but especially during
passover pastor is about freedom pastor
is about prayer and thanks to god we
definitely have additional prayers added
to have our brothers and sisters in mind
and try and make bring some more peace
into the world
let's talk about some of the traditions
here you've brought some fine fine food
some fine drink uh talk about some of
the traditions here yeah so there's two
passover seders it's traditional dinner
tonight and tomorrow night this is the
shmura matzah the handmade matzah
doesn't taste so good spiritually tastes
good but uh it tastes like cardboard
sometimes people tell me it's a flat
bread right we've got the seder plate
each item on the seder plate has meaning
and tradition it's all about teaching
the children that's what passover is all
about so they asked questions the four
questions we have the the haroset is the
mortar supposed to resemble the bricks
and mortar when the jews were enslaved
in egypt we've got the more the
horseradish bitter again to represent
and symbolize the bitterness of the hard
work while the jews weren't stayed in
egypt we've got this is that the chicken
neck and the egg represents the
sacrifices brought in the temple
while the jews were serving in the
temple and then we have the four cups of
wine or grape juice during the passover
seder okay and what are some of the
events that are happening around las
vegas uh to mark passover so this
passover slaters khabar has all over the
town there's i think 10 community
staters thousands of jews will be
gathering together tonight and tomorrow
night to celebrate you want to go on our
website check it out it's getting a
little bit late in rsvp the time to do
so is now
but tonight and tomorrow night celebrate
passover celebrate our freedom together
with the rest of the community all right
very well it's uh it's a wonderful
tradition and and one that we respect
and learn about more i think every year
and it's uh there's so many celebrations
going on right now passover easter
ramadan
yeah thank you so much rabbi for coming
in thank you for having me let's
everyone have a happy and healthy
passover absolutely thanks a lot for
having me i appreciate that